now I know what you're thinking why does
his face look like a giant nut I don't
know what happened bros I my beard is
gone I was gonna trim it and then it
just fell off I'm like what happened I
should probably go to a doctor but I
don't know we're still a little there
huh I have some updates for you bros I'm
scratching my balls and you have no idea
you do now anyone still watching we're
gonna play some games together bros yeah
it's been way too long and I always
really enjoy hanging out and you're
interacting with you bros so I thought
we're gonna play some smite again
together I had so much fun last time
it's a really fun game and it's free to
play which means all of you bros who
wants to play can participate so that's
pretty cool if you want to play some
games with me we're gonna do it next
week I'm gonna livestream the whole
thing it's gonna be amazing
and if you want to participate all you
have to do is go to smite game comm I'll
leave a link in the description and you
can sign up start training get good if
you want to play with me you gotta be
one of the best last time we lost all
our games I don't know why there must be
like a weak link I don't understand
oh yeah hey like I said it's always so
much fun hanging out with you bros and I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun so yeah
if you want to participate smite
game.com sign up trained up nipple up
you got it
I have some more updates for you bros
then the second one is
[Music]
so yeah you can wear them like this if
you want highest fashion they walk down
like this in the runway in Paris oh yeah
I wore these in a picture and every one
of your birds like why can't we get down
I need these pants maybe not like that
but they're available now you can check
them out in the description as well say
fabulous bras stay fabulous it also
tells time the watch is not included but
it's pretty useful
wipe your nose with it that like the
possibilities are endless another update
is that the indie vs. PewDiePie Jam is
happening right now if you want check
out and help me play the games and help
me out by voting for them the top 10
highest voted games I will play in a
video so that should be pretty
interesting play some games have some
fun it's free and it's cool my address
um I got a little secret for you you're
awesome and never forget it
thank you for being a bro it means so
much to me I love you both each and
every one of you stay awesome and I'll
see you in the next one brofist